countries across europe are imposing
tighter restrictions in the hope of
slowing the spread of the coronavirus as
cases continue to rise
france has recorded a new high of 32 000
cases in a single day
authorities there have brought in a
curfew in major cities requiring all
public spaces to be shut by 9 pm
and in germany chancellor angela merkel
has warned of difficult months ahead
with almost
8 000 new infections recorded in the
past day
the highest figure since the start of
the pandemic the chancellor has appealed
to germans
to work together and urge them to stay
at home as much as possible
italy is set to announce tough new
national restrictions
as it battles its own surge in cases the
government
has already twice tightened the rules in
the last 10 days
including making masks mandatory outside
the home
the aim is to avoid another full
lockdown to limit the damage to the
economy
fatima negrini has seen a lot in her 108
years
she survived the spanish flu two world
wars
and now covet 19. when the first wave of
the pandemic hits milan
she lost many of her friends in the care
home she lives in
one i've lived through so much in my
life
and i'm still here it looks like god has
forgotten about me
fatima nagrini feels lucky here in
northern italy
and wants to help others lombardi was
badly hit by the pandemic in spring
with the virus claiming thousands of
lives and care homes for the elderly
in particular 33 000
died of covet 19 in italy and almost
half of them here in the north
hospitals were overwhelmed the situation
was dramatic
as van de gadi recalls
she's a volunteer with the italian white
cross on sundays
she worked 12 hours straight i was there
to
give him help but
i asked him to come with me alone
so this was one of the
strange experiences very different from
before
because during the normal period
we take the patients and the relative
or the caregiver with us on the
ambulance to go to the hospital
for many help came too late the campo 87
section of the city cemetery
houses the graves of 128 unclaimed covet
19 victims
buried in a hurry when the contagion
risk was high
either their relatives couldn't be found
or couldn't organize funerals because
they were ill or quarantining
it may now be made a permanent monument
commemorating the victims of covert 19.
we lived in a very traumatic experience
like a tsunami something that in at the
moment
arrived and changed completely
everything
so from that moment we changed our
behavior our approach to
the life now in autumn it's still
mandatory to wear a mask inside all
buildings and also from six in the
evening until six
in the morning on crowded streets italy
is doing everything it can to avoid a
second lockdown
for weeks and spring people weren't
allowed to leave their homes
the strict approach explains why italy
has managed to avert a second wave
says maria rita gizmondo she runs the
covert 19 lab
at the luigi sarco university hospital
in milan
italians learned valuable lessons from
the high death rates in march and april
gizmondo would like to see more
cross-border cooperation
i think an important thing
is to think at the european health
to have the same protocol of therapy
the same to exchange experiences
the same current thing not just the loca
localized health but just matter you
know european strategy
to face the viruses tusmondo believes
that the key is rapid response
the italian government has introduced
covert 19 tests in schools that provide
rapid results
mateo and his sister victoria welcome
such measures
the last thing they want is another
lockdown and a return to homeschooling
[Music]
but i am deeply worried about everyone
else no sure
comments i don't know if he needed in
the meantime
she prays and hopes for the best
fatima's determination
and endurance has made her a role model
to many
qualities needed now more than ever
let's bring in correspondent sema gupta
in rome
sema italy two reporting record daily
cases
how's the situation right now
well the situation we're seeing is
really a steady spike in the number of
kovit 19 cases the new cases
just on saturday 10 925
new cases another highest daily tally
that we've seen in fact there have been
daily
records being set it's an alarming rise
if you compare to the fact that just a
week ago that was
half the figure but it's also important
to note that the amount of
testing is also at a record high uh
on saturday as well more than 165
000 tests were carried out in the
country so those figures are really
significantly higher in terms of the
number of tests as compared to what the
situation was
back in march and april uh the death
toll unfortunately
also on saturday another 47 people
are said to have succumbed to covet 19
but it's not the figures again of what
we were seeing at the height of the
pandemic of more than
900 daily deaths so an interesting
factor perhaps to look at is the
admissions into the intensive care unit
because that's creeping up it's now
about 705
compared to just 40 back in july so
really the authorities are saying
we're at an acute phase and the virus is
circulating
throughout the country the rules have
already been
tightened there what other measures are
being discussed
well uh the government is said to be
meeting uh
local as well as regional leaders
they're also discussing with the
health and a scientific community and
some of the things that are being
discussed are things like perhaps
closing high schools altogether
uh perhaps even closing non-essential
activities such as
gyms schools and pools and sporting
events all together but we'll have to
wait and see what they decide we do know
uh since last week as you mentioned mars
now required
at all uh public areas outdoors or
indoors
restaurants and bars have shut down off
midnight
and they can only have turbo table
service from 9 p.m
so really i think people are concerned
are we going to see a curfew like what's
happening in france
uh or is it going to be a little bit
less uh the government has said for the
moment they've put in place
a stimulus package to try and help the
hardest hit companies that have been
affected by the coronavirus lockdown
uh putting together some 4 billion euros
for that
well that will be well received i'm sure
but how are people coping i mean they
must are they
are they scared i think there's
really an increased level of concern no
one wants to see
an extreme lockdown or the number of
deaths that we saw at the height of the
pandemic here in italy
let's not forget this country lost more
than 36 000
lives to covet 19. so really on the
street i think there is a level of
concern it depends which age group you
speak to
uh there is a concern that the young in
particular are not taking this
seriously enough but mars are seen on
the street people
are wearing it they are sticking to it
but really there's a feeling here
summer is over and we're looking at a
fairly long winter ahead of us
all right see my gupta in rome thanks
very much